hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game played in 1978 between Swiss
International Master of Abner hug and
none other than Viktor Korchnoi who I
believe needs no introduction before we
check out this very nice game I would
just like to thank everyone for your
detail the feedback about the
merchandise I see where you're going and
what you are expecting and I will
definitely try to make it happen
sometimes perhaps during December and I
also would like to show this very nice
tweet to you that was tweeted by Garry
Kasparov about yesterday's game
regarding that better pitch for move and
the entire force checkmates that says I
suggested Kasparov says that the
computer shows black wins with 68 Bishop
to h4 here but head Caruana played the
incredible defense with Bishop 2d and
not defense but Bishop to b5 and 92
Bishop to f3 and the nice to g1 that is
the winning sequence they would request
metal detectors immediately saying that
I know human can you know conceived such
an idea that they would immediately
think that Caruana was cheating
Kasparov says that not no human can
willingly trap his own knight like that
which definitely I agree and I didn't
think that there was any chance that
this would would have been played but
you know mmm Khurana wasn't too upset
when he heard that he missed it as and
he definitely shouldn't be and Kasper
also mentioned on Twitter that he
himself in his prime he doesn't consider
that he would find this sequence as
there's no logic behind it yet there's
no way for you to even start finding the
moves or even think that it's actually
winning so that's one thing I wanted to
mention and the other one is something
I've already mentioned on my social
media I've received a beautiful photo
from an excellent subscriber his name is
George there you have it this is George
and this is what he sent me there you
see he has a very nice painting that's
Magnus Carlsen in there George sealing
across Magnus Carlsen over his table and
me over there in the back it was a gift
from his wife Elena and
I can only imagine through how much
trouble she went to make something like
this happen but it's really a beautiful
piece and I'm I'm really honored to you
know hang on some wall alongside such a
such an excellent person like like
George here and of course a wheelchair
champion Magnus Carlsen and here we have
an enlarged version of it so you know
just you know take take a moment to
appreciate it it's a very nice I was
actually staring it for quite quite some
time it's really just a wonderful piece
so there we have it now let's check out
this game I thought after this really
exhausting game not game but exhausting
six games of the World Chess
Championship 2018 that we would enjoy a
nice breeder so there you have it Swiss
International Master Gardener Hogg vs.
Viktor Korchnoi and it's very
interesting the game was played in 1978
in 1978 Cornell also challenged Anatoly
Karpov for the title so you can imagine
how strong Viktor Korchnoi was here and
some of you may not know this out of all
the games they played the corner against
Karpov
fortunately won five games and Karp of
won six games so only one game
difference in 21 games were drawn
because then the rule was a first person
to achieve six wins so a quarter was a
very very close to take the World Chess
Championship title away from Karpov but
we'll already introduced culture in some
of my videos and we're gonna go some
more into course on his life and
everything
most likely one we'll be covering the
doing the Corp of Series but also I
don't mind doing a course series either
so who knows what we'll encounter in the
future whereas Verner hug he was a he
was at the Junior World Chess Champion
in 1971 and during the 1970s one of the
strongest Swiss grandmasters or one of
the strongest Swiss player says he was
an international masters and he competed
for the Swiss Olympic team 11 times so
definitely a nice clash of course the
victor cornered by fire by far the
but it's really an enjoyable game and
I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it so let's
dive straight into it Knight to f3 by
Verner hug
so the Reiki opening we have e six
basically keeping black ischaemic his
options open this can now easily
transpose into something like even the
Queens gambit declined after d4 let's
say B 5 c4 Knight to f6 but this is one
of the games where we do not transpose
into the Queens gambit declined after 6
we have g3 preparing to finger the
lights worship d5 by fortunately Bishop
to g2 and now C 5 so question is really
going after that center with the pawns
and as it usually goes when you play the
ready opening our white wants to control
the center with his pieces we have
castles and not Knight to c6 and here we
have c4
so now Porsche has an option he can just
continue developing maybe Knight to f6
he can even decide to put the pawn now
if d4 yes black does grab a lot of space
but then after white challenges the
center you can play something like a
knight to f6 but then after captures
captures in d3 what white actually has a
decent position after black develops the
wife can go Bishop to g5 and the game
goes on nothing to be you know upset
about but after c4 Viktor decides to
abandon the center a very interesting
choice yes he does have a you know a
very nice center here he plays d
captures on c4 and now white will
usually go after this pawn with
something like Knights 283 but here a
veteran or goes with Queen to a4 now
going after the pawn this way Victor
continues developing Bishop to d7 and
now comes Queen captures on c4 and now
look the c8 Knight to c3 here you could
immediately go after the center with d4
but Knight the c3 is needed to the
regard to the B 5 squared here after d4
black would have this very annoying b5
move so now of course you cannot capture
with the Queen because you get
Knights to be for the
is now attacking the Queen and after the
Queen moves you can capture or open up
the see file and after Queen moves now
you get night the c2 you attack the
Queen and the rook you will lose the
exchange here and well most likely the
game so after rope to see it first
Knight to c3 to control the b v square
we have knife to f6 and now comes d4 and
okay now here Victor decides to go b5
you know regardless of everything and
there we have it B 5
so what happens here okay you still
don't want to capture with the Queen if
you capture with the Queen now you get D
captures on C C capture sandy for
attacking the knight and after the
knight moves now nice to be for open
opening up an attack against the Queen
still you're gonna face moves like
Knight to the c2 not something you want
to go after but what happens if you play
Knight captures on b5 that's also very
interesting if Knight characters then
Knight to a5 attacks the Queen on c4 but
the Queen also has to keep an eye on the
knight on b5 so after Queen to a4 now
you get rook to b8 the night is now
attacked twice and there's really not
all that much you can do after Bishop to
d2 attacking the knight black will
simply capture the night and now the
night and a5 is also defended twice but
still it's not all that week after
Knight to d5 we would still have a very
complicated an interesting game but
white doesn't want to go into that after
b5 we have Queen to d3 simply getting
out of the way and now C captures on d4
Viktor also had this option of pushing
c4
but then after Queen moves also you can
push b4 after the knight moves captures
captures and now black can simply
continue developing but still you would
push a5 it would be a very nice pawn
formation on the Queen side but nothing
white really needs to worry about so
Victor has a different idea see captures
on d4 we have Knight captures on d4 and
now Knight not capturing before but
rather Knight to e5 attacking the Queen
Queen moves back to d1 pretty much the
safest square you don't want to go
anywhere near the two knights
and now Queen to b6 a nice developing
move by the Queen and also it brings
further protections that the b5 phone so
black also has to be careful Victor's
King is still in the center of the board
and if white can develop from the bishop
and get the rook to c1 it could also get
very dangerous for Victor brush up to g5
of course white wants to develop as well
get the rook into the game Bishop to e7
and now rook the c1 and quarter decides
to finally Castle Knight back to f3
offering an exchange of knights with
Knight captures the Bishop captures and
look after d8 here black fully mobilized
his forces and white wants to do the
same he wants to get his Queen into the
game bring the other look over to d1
which is exactly what Verner does we
have Queen to b3 but now white is
basically one move away from complete
development but Victor then I seem that
we have before and here we kind of
entered a critical moment of the game
where White has to decide what to do
with the knight of course you can't move
it to d1 because then you're rockin c1
would be unprotected what you can do is
play Knights the b1 this would be a
viable option if the rooks are exchanged
and the knight can come back into the
game via d2 and maybe then the e4 also
an idea is actually but characters on f6
eliminate d f6 a knight first and now
not capturing with the bishop because
then you allow 94 to come with an attack
on the bishop but the G captures and
only now you move the knight back to b1
and again it would be it would be
playable for white our black would be
better but it would be better than what
why did decided to do in the game in the
game nights the e4 was played but now
there is a problem here a victor plays
Knight captures on e4 and now you can no
longer capture here if you play virtual
captures then the bishop on g5 is
unguarded Bishop captures and black is
actually up a piece on the other hand
after Knight captures you don't really
have the option of capturing and c8 if
you play this then you get simply Knight
captures on g5 and after Luke capture
sandy is a Queen captures on d8 you
would have a bishop and the night for a
look so two pieces are
much more valuable than a rook black
would be much better here
so white doesn't really have all that
much options after night captures on e4
Bishop captures on e7 was played but now
comes rope captures on c1 removing the
defender of the f2 pawn rook captures on
f1 and now comes Queen captures on f2 as
DF dewpoint is no longer guarded King to
f1 and now comes look to see a truck to
see it a very powerful move because
white can't really afford to capture it
if route captures Bishop captures you're
in a lot of trouble here you can't
capture for example Bishop captures will
lead to the Queen to f1 checkmate so you
would have to go into a very passive
position with Queen to d1 but still it
would be losing because if Oh Queen to
d1 then I'm sure you will see it Queen
captures on f3 with Czech pawn captures
night after checking moves Knight
captures black is up a piece and winning
the game so after loop the c8 Vernor
decided that there is no real point in
capturing the route Queen goes back to
d1 but it's not much better here of
course not played rook captures on c1 we
have Queen captures on c1 and now you
are black here feel free to pause the
video and continue this attack for black
I will give you a couple of seconds as
usual for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent player and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show here
Victor played Bishop to c6 which is an
excellent move placing this Bishop on
the same diagonal as is occupied by the
White King and the problem is you can't
capture it if you captured it with the
Queen again you face the screen to f1
checkmate and if you don't capture it
what do you what do you play here
white white here thought that there was
a there he couldn't capture the bishop
but there was no real danger from black
and here white actually just captured
the pawn here Bishop captures on before
but now once again you are Viktor
Korchnoi feel free to pause the video
here and win this game with black what
does black play here what is the
strongest move into position I'll give
you a couple of seconds
to find it for those of you who were
able to do it once again congratulations
like Victor you are also terrible
and for those who just want to enjoyed
show here Victor played Queen captures
no need to and it was in this position
unmoved 24 that Swiss International
Master Bernhard hug decided to resign in
the game what did he resign well there
are a couple of things you can do here
obviously one one of the options is to
capture the Queen if you capture with
the bishop then comes Knight captures on
g3 with check and notice that the queen
is once again up occupying the C 1
square you cannot go to g2 with the King
as the bishop is covering the entire
diagonal you have to go a king to G 1
because it's a double check from the
night ends of the bishop King do you
want now comes night chapters on e2 it's
a very nice fork the king is in check
the Queen is under attack King F 1 Queen
tap the night captures here and again a
black is up a piece but not only up a
piece but up two points as well so
easily winning on the other hand after
Queen captures an e to capturing the
bishop air leads to the exact same Queen
to f1 checkmate and even if you don't go
that if you try something like Queen to
d1 which doesn't make sense as I mean
the Queen and Bishop are guarding each
other very nicely here the problem is
nice to have to check King moves and now
not capturing the Queen but actually
Knight to h3 check King moves and now
Bishop captures on f3 is again checkmate
so it's really really simply a wonderful
position after Bishop to b4 Queen
captures on e to all of these different
checkmates involving the checkmates with
the Queen without the Queen it's simply
beautiful and I really thought you might
enjoy this one after such such an
intense such intense six games of the
World Chess Championship 2018 so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
one short announcement I created this
court server so so those of you who
enjoyed the discord or is a discord I
don't know are welcome to check it out I
will put it will be the first thing you
will see in the description below so
there's already a
small community that everyone is
chatting with everyone there are a lot
of different topics you know a lot of
moderators already well not a lot but
but some you know it's growing so feel
free to join you know there are a lot of
fun topics there like chess jokes like
discussion about the World Chess
Championship and well there's not a lot
since I only created it today but it's
growing and you're welcome to you know
just drop by and and have a nice chat
with someone now I will also be you know
chatting there and you know perhaps
showing some funny photos or or
something
a Badia I would like to thank Steve
Miranda
Jen's Burkhart David Kiser amar Samaria
and Robert McLaughlin for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous video er thank you for watching
and I will see you soon hopefully with
another game as brilliant as this one
that was played by Victor the terrible
Sam thank you all and I will see you
soon